highest rated gm uh high sorry blitz  player are beaten on leeches really  really impressed  highest rated blitz player you're beaten  in blitz  that's a good story bro that's uh very  sorry  what's your story i don't know you know  i haven't i can't compete with this no  okay meanwhile i think i'm doing well in  this game  on 94 i didn't see we'll take it g6  the cow also believed  that's a bit of an unfortunate name in  norwegian but i guess in russian it's  fine  you speak russian no i don't know  we know some words  we all do yeah we all do  spay four  now the bishop pair is strong i'm  gradually getting more influence over  the position  he's uh  he's playing decently but i don't think  it will be enough  remind me later stop bothering me  uh  did i mess something up  probably not  queen e6 there's going to  oh there was rookie one but still  okay now i just take  now comes with the winning this pawn is  auto promoting  this point  okay